bonsoir double victoire française aux 24
heures du mans du mans automobiles c'est
un des grands titres de l'actualité de
ce dimanche contre juin double victoire
parce que c'est un constructeur français
qui a gagné pour la première fois
renault l'emportent 24 heures dans son
duel contre porsche et victoires pour
deux pilotes français jean pierre
jaussaud 42 ans l'aîné et didier pironi
26 ans l'un des plus jeunes pilotes à ce
niveau c'est la revanche de la régie
renault sur porsche
vainqueur l'an dernier la marque
allemand ne termine que deuxième avec x
wollek ébats autre titre de sport le
suédois borg vainqueur pour la troisième
fois des internationaux de france de
tennis à roland garros et en football
dans la coupe du monde un grand point
d'interrogation encore le brésil qui
mène actuellement 1 0 contre l'autriche
sera-t-il éliminé ce soir de la coupe du
monde
nous reviendrons sur cette actualité
sportive à la fin du journal c'est à
dire dans 25 minutes à peu près et pour
commencer je vous propose des images du
sauvetage du skylab sauvetage le mot
n'est pas trop fort et c'est ce qu'ont
réussi les américains qui ont fait
basculer sur lui même dans l'espace cet
engin laboratoire de 80 tonnes et qui a
bien failli retomber sur terre en se
désintégrant avec tous les risques que
cela comporte
philippe rochot trois équipages avaient
habité skylab du temps de sa splendeur
en 74
mais depuis le laboratoire spatial
allait à la dérive et se déplaçait même
perpendiculairement à la terre il
offrait ainsi une résistance à
l'atmosphère et perdaient
progressivement de l'altitude
quand on sait que skylab ps 80 tonnes et
mesurent france 5 mètres de long ou
comprends l'inquiétude de la nasa qui
craignaient aussi de perdre cet
observatoire exceptionnelle du soleil à
400 km de distance les techniciens de la
nasa ont pu actionner les gyroscopes de
skylab pour que le satellite retrouve
son équilibre
skylab est sauvé pour six mois et tout
danger est écarté pour le moment à
l'automne prochain une navette spatiale
doit emmener une fusée auxiliaire pour
replacer le satellite à une altitude
supérieure
mais cette navette est loin d'être
terminée
entre la nasa et skylab une nouvelle
course contre la montre se trouve ainsi
engagé
événement politique du week-end la
présence de françois mitterrand premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste au club
de la fraise d'europe
il répondait aux questions de plusieurs
journalistes dont noël copains d'antenne
2 et françois mitterrand dans les
copains a essentiellement parlé de
politique étrangère mais oui tout la
première la plus grande partie de cette
émission était consacrée la politique
étrangère notamment aux problèmes des
africains alors je vous cite tout de
suite quelques phrases chocs de françois
mitterrand ce n'est pas en devenant les
cubains de l'occident que la france
remplira son meilleur rôle en afrique et
monsieur mitterrand estime que la
politique africaine de la france
comportent des risques et des dangers
d'hôtes anisation à travers ce
néologisme si vous les comprenez le
risque et le danger d'une réinsertion
dans le tan dans le pacte atlantique
mais monsieur mitterrand affirme
cependant que dès lors que des français
se trouvent menacés il y a un devoir
d'assistance qui s'impose alors pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore parlé des
problèmes internes du parti cécile pour
tout vous dire on commençait à en parler
quand j'ai quitté l'europe pour venir
ici
converser les groupes portant il ya des
prix liée à des postes internes au parti
socialiste on en parle beaucoup depuis
les élections leur salut pour les
comprendre je crois qu'il faut résumer
la situation rapidement en rappelant
qu'il ya au sein des partis socialistes
quatre grandes tendances ou quatre
grands courants de pensée comme l'on dit
il et les amis de monsieur mitterrand
constitué pour la plus grande part les
anciens de la convention des
institutions républicaines
il ya les anciens de la série ou en
particulier avec monsieur moreau avec
monsieur de faire il y a les anciens du
psu qui ont rallié le ps avec michel
rocard en 1974 et iliad le crs or depuis
maintenant trois ans les trois premiers
courant de pensée forment la majorité et
le crs lui forment la minorité alors on
peut faire une première constatation
depuis sept ans si cette constatation ce
qu'il ya un relâchement dans les liens
qui unissent les trois tendances de la
majorité
surtout depuis que messieurs mauroy et
rocard font figure pour certains de
dauphin possible de monsieur françois
mitterrand et ils viennent question qui
se pose est ce que on ne va pas assister
une redistribution des cartes et ce qui
ne sera pas un changement de majorité ou
les devrait avoir une majorité contre le
crs c'est ce qui ne risque pas d'y avoir
un jour une majorité barrant la route de
michel ange alors quel est d'après vous
la signification exacte de ses besoins
réels de personnes présentes là un peu
rapidement ça fait et querelles de
personnes querelles de clans ou querelle
de famille un peu politique politicienne
mais il faut se dire quand même que là
derrière
il ya une question qui a quand même son
importance quand on sait ce qui s'est
passé à d'autres élections
présidentielles c'est de savoir qui sera
effectivement le représentant du parti
socialiste aux élections présidentielles
de 1981 et il est certain que et dans le
passé c'est la stature de françois
mitterrand qui était le principal
facteur de l'unité du parti socialiste
de son plein gré depuis 1971 justement
parce que monsieur françois mitterrand
était le meilleur candidat possible du
parti socialiste et de toute façon pour
1981 il faut pour le parti socialiste
trouver un candidat qui soit crédible
contre monsieur giscard d'estaing car il
est à peu près certain maintenant que
les yeux de monsieur rares seront
exaucés et que monsieur giscard
d'estaing se représentera en tout cas
tous les observateurs le pensent et
deuxièmement question subsidiaire il
faut aussi pour le parti socialiste
trouver un candidat qui devant ces mêmes
qui distance le candidat du parti
communiste car on sait aussi qu'ils
eurent un candidat du parti communiste
or si le parti socialiste était distancé
aux élections présidentielles par les
partis communistes se serait il un échec
plus dur encore que la défaite de la
gauche en 1968 alors me direz il reste
trois en trois ans que le parti
socialiste compte consacrée en grande
partie à la réflexion et à la
préparation elle risque de se voir
justement si ce délai sera consacrée à
la réflexion ou s'il sera consacrée aux
querelles
merci de make up un autre actualité
politique de ce week end la fête du ps
eut dans le parc paysager de la
courneuve dans la banlieue parisienne
deux jours de fête pour les militants du
parti socialiste unifié les socialistes
autogestionnaire comme chaque année on a
retrouvé l'aspect détente avec de la
musique de la danse et des animations
diverses
et puis un aspect politique aussi avec
normalement des débats mais là
apparemment les militants ont été
quelque peu déçus claude sérillon
oui côté politique un certain
désenchantement beaucoup de militants
d'extrême gauche peut être en effet des
débats des explications après les
élections de mars dernier
mais faute de communistes ou de
socialistes officiels
le débat reste à interne
ce qui nous paraît inquiétant et ce
contre quoi il va falloir véritablement
lutter maintenant c'est que finalement
les états majors se crisper sur eux
mêmes après cet échec et n'accepte pas
qu'il puisse y avoir un véritable débat
et je crois que c'est pour ça qu'en
réalité les direction du parti
communiste et du parti socialiste ont
décidé de ne pas participer à nos débats
c'est une crispation se retire sur soi
alors qu'il faudrait au contraire ouvrir
le débat a invité tout le monde à
réfléchir sur ce qui s'est passé pour en
tirer des conclusions pour le plaisir de
revenir sur le passé sur la passe est
désagréable et pour en tirer des
conclusions positives quand l'avenir
voilà ce qui n'est pas fait actuellement
mais ce que nous voulons faire c'est à
dire que nous allons faire le maximum
pour que chacun puisse s'approprier ce
débat est pas le laisser entre les mains
simplement les directions rebours le
cartel cgt de renault propose d arrêt de
travail de deux heures dès mardi dans
toutes les usines du groupe pour
protester contre l'évacuation par la
police
cette semaine les usines de flins et de
cléon il y avait une élection
sénatoriale partielle en haute-loire
aujourd'hui pour remplacer monsieur jean
proriol du parti républicain qui a été
élu député en mars dernier au premier
tour ce matin monsieur gouteyron rpr est
arrivé en tête des trois candidats se
réclamant de la majorité présidentielle
et au cours du deuxième tour cet après
midi monsieur gouteyron a été élu
sénateur
la politique encore mais en italie cette
fois 41 millions d'électeurs italiens
doivent dire aujourd'hui et demain par
voie de référendum s'ils sont pour ou
contre l'abrogation des lois actuelles
sur l'ordre public et pour ou contre le
financement des partis politiques peu
par l'état victor vraiment notre
correspondant à rome a suivi pour nous
cette campagne électorale et le
déroulement du scrutin
pour l'écrasante majorité des forces
politiques en italie
ce référendum c'est tout simplement une
provocation des radicaux ces radicaux
qui n'ont que quatre députés au
parlement mais qui malheureusement il si
grande influence sur les jeunes pour les
radicaux c'est une fête
ils ont réussi à provoquer ce référendum
destiné à supprimer le financement par
l'état des partis politiques et une loi
sur l'ordre public votée il ya trois ans
que l'on appelle la loire est allée du
nom de son auteur que l'on conteste le
mode de financement des partis oui
pourquoi pas mais ce qui crée le
scandale c'est que les radicaux veulent
supprimer une loi qui en principe est le
seul instrument légal dont dispose le
gouvernement contre la criminalité le
terrorisme
c'est vrai qu'elle a été votée à 75,78
et même le ministre de l'intérieur il a
dû avouer l'année les communistes ont
été les plus actifs dans cette campagne
contre la proposition des radicaux de
supprimer la loi sur l'ordre public
il ya trois ans les communistes avaient
pourtant voté contre cette loi jugée
trop répressive mais en ce temps là les
communistes étaient encore dans
l'opposition
maintenant ils sont dans la majorité
gouvernementale avec les
démocrates-chrétiens abete
et clermont sociopolitique il faut
rompre c'était monopole de la dimension
politique et cette majorité qui s'est
déterminé avec les des parties précis
pour la démocratie chrétienne le parti
communiste en même temps les radicaux
ils ont fait une campagne acharnée
contre les parlements vous savez année
là même au fond dit le parlement c'est
chez vous c'est
les véritables
même les condamner pour france aux
discussions de l'état il a il a dit que
les palmes à cet engouement et spylo
commandes in italy c'est à dire pas
demandé [ __ ] et cetera cette année
qu'il a organisé une campagne contre les
parisiens
la fonction du patrimoine et il emploie
les chemins du référendum pourrait
démolir les pouvoirs du parlement
c'est évident il y aura une majorité
contre l'abrogation des lois sur le
financement des partis lors de public
des communistes aux démocrates-chrétiens
85% des partis politiques veulent
continuer de recevoir des fonds publics
on les comprend et pensent qu'il faut
conserver la loire et al
quitte à la modifier du moins les
radicaux ont réussi à provoquer une
belle bataille à secouer la torpeur des
italiens qui grâce à ce référendum vont
peut être se demander s'il n'ya pas
effectivement quelque chose à faire pour
combattre plus efficacement le
terrorisme à l'étranger ont causé
quelques télégrammes révélations du new
york times fidel castro le premier
ministre cubain aurait essayé de
s'opposer à la tacc des ex gendarme
qu'attendait contre la province du shaba
au zaïre il en aurait même informé
washington
autre révélation encore plus au
conditionnel celle là celle de
l'observeur journal anglais on croit
savoir que le général mobutu le
président du zaïre recruterait
actuellement deux mille mercenaires
venant d'italie de suisse de belgique et
de france au portugal
les incidents qui ont marqué la fête
nationale hier incidents provoqués par
des affrontements entre manifestants
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche ont
fait un mort et cinq blessés graves à
lisbonne et dix autres blessés à porto à
lisbonne je vous rappelle que la police
ait dû tirer en l'air pour disperser les
manifestants
réunion demain lundi à copenhague des
ministres des affaires étrangères du
marché commun les neufs vont parler
essentiellement du zaïre et de l'afrique
il y aura également sur leur table un
autre dossier celui de l'entrée de la
grèce dans le marché commun l'un des
problèmes particuliers soulevées par
cette adhésion de la grèce et celui de
l'agriculture
comme souvent les européens ont peur de
la concurrence
ne soyez pas inquiets répondent les
grecs nous aurions temps déjà nos
productions pour devenir non pas
concurrents mais complémentaires
alors bernard marchetti et allez le
constater sur place
c'est l'image classique du pâtre grec
qui semble porter sur son noble visage
toute la sagesse du vieux monde comme le
font souvent les belles images et la
crédite une idée fausse
celle d'une agriculture grec archaïque
engoncée dans la tradition isolé dans
ces vallées et dans ses îles
celle inverse qui est vrai on ne peut
pas distinguer ici les exploitations
agricoles modernes et traditionnelles
tout se trouve en voie de modernisation
mais à des degrés divers la mécanisation
est très développé six cent mille
machines agricoles pour trois millions
cinq cent mille hectares cultivés 874
mille hectares sont irriguées soit 24%
du total avec des possibilités
d'extension jusqu'à 44%
la culture sous serre est bien maîtrisée
et suffisamment répandu ici en crète à
hier à petra l'essai recouvre 450
hectares elles permettent une production
intensive spécialisée surtout des
concombres des tomates en primeur qui
sont exportés à 80% sur le marché de
munich c'est à dire déjà dans la
communauté
en dehors des nécessités de la
consommation locale toute la production
de fruits et légumes et du reste
orientée vers les primeurs le climat s'y
prête
la précocité est telle qu'il en découle
parfois une sorte de monopole sur le
marché international en fonction de
l'éventuelle adhésion de la grèce à la
communauté européenne cette orientation
est actuellement accentué de façon à
offrir une production complémentaire et
non pas concurrentiel on espère ainsi
désarmer les réticences des milieux
agricoles français et italiens
ces industries de soutien l'agriculture
sont développées et bien réparties sur
le territoire
les fabrique d'emballage et surtout les
stations de conditionnement sont
modernes et adaptés à la demande
elles ont été créées grâce aux
financements de la banque nationale
agricole un organisme d'état encadrés et
conseillés par des ingénieurs agronomes
les chefs d'exploitation ont
généralement une bonne qualification
certains d'entre eux utilisent des
techniques de pointe et vont jusqu'aux
limites du possible
ce n'est pas qu'une question de
technique il faut compter avec la nature
les abeilles assurent la pollinisation
des fleurs de fraisiers qu'après le 20
février
alors j'ai les premières fraises famars
pas avant ce sont les abeilles qui
commande
mais l'agriculture grecque a aussi c'est
pesant terre est d'abord le trop grand
nombre de ruraux 24 % de la population
active du pays
c'est énorme dans la communauté la
moyenne est de 10 % pour tenir son rôle
dans la communauté où elle place tant
d'espoirs
la grèce va devoir s'adapter aux normes
européennes résorber l'excédent de
population agricole ce qui signifie
développer l'industrie pour créer des
emplois
de 1957 pour cela bien des réticences
souhaitez-vous ou craignez-vous
l'adhésion la grèce au marché commun
peut-être houle a souhaité et vous la
craignant même temps je la crains et je
vais la désire en même temps les
agriculteurs grecs seront assurées de
vendre leurs produits et ils obtiendront
de meilleurs prix mais l'agriculture et
avec elle toute l'économie grecque
seront obligés à la fois de se
moderniser
accélérer et de se réorganiser plus
rationnellement
ce sera un grand choc et une grande
mutation heureusement l'agriculture
grecque et dynamique adaptable au reste
elle sera complémentaire et non pas
concurrentiels dans la communauté
elle ne plaira pas un problème de plus
et puis l'aspect économique est
secondaire l'important c'est le
changement politique social et culturel
auquel l'adhésion nous conduire à nous
nous sentons européen et en même temps
isolés l'europe nous donnera au sens
large un sentiment de sécurité
si cela l' avantage réel de l'adhésion
derrière la volonté de s'arrimer à
l'europe se profile le souci de
consolider la nouvelle démocratie
grecque et de se garantir contre un
éventuel retour de l'expansionnisme turc
en grèce la question nationale brille
tout même l'économie et les agriculteurs
le savent bien
en bref maintenant attentats la nuit
dernière contre le siège du club
méditerranée à paris trois explosions
ont détruit une bonne partie de
l'immeuble et blessé le gardien cet
attentat a été revendiqué par un
mouvement raciste inconnue le front de
libération national français miracle
hamelin un enfant de 5 ans est sorti
vivant d'une chute de six étages
il est tombé accidentellement par la
fenêtre d'un immeuble sa chute a été
amortie par la pelouse il est tout de
même blessé il a été hospitalisé le
sport avec une journée particulièrement
chargée et trois grands duels dans trois
disciplines différentes aux 24 heures du
mans automobiles duel renault porsche
donc
renault a gagné en football brésil
autriche réponse dans quelques minutes
et puis en tennis finales des
internationaux de france duels borg
vilas et c'est le suédois borg qui a
gagné très facilement
le suédois a remporté les internationaux
de france pour la troisième fois
égalant ainsi le record du français
henri cochet
résultat du match 6 1 6 1 6 3 guillermo
vilas a subi la loi du livre de cordes
ou plus pas un tennis de grande qualité
l'efficacité du suédois nous a prouvé du
spectacle mais c'est grâce à elle qu'il
a pu remporter ses internationaux sans
concéder un seul set en plus de la
gloire il empoche la coquette somme de
21 mille francs chez les femmes c'est la
roumaine rasic si pierre batut la
tchécoslovaque jovette en coupe du monde
de football
actuellement l'équipe du brésil est en
train d'obtenir une laborieuse
qualification pour le deuxième tour en
battant l'autriche 1 à 0 grâce à un but
de roberto à la 40e minute
au même moment à vélez l'espagne même
devant la suède 1 but à 0 on n'a pas
retrouvé le génie créateur ni le
football romantique des brésiliens trois
fois champions du monde et sept au stade
j ai bien le symbole d'une coupe du
monde décevante par excès de réalisme en
plus quelques images du direct puisque
le match va se terminer dans quelques
minutes les à côté de cette coupe du
monde la sphère des maillots savez le
gag de l'équipe de france d'hier va
quand même un risque de coûter 20
millions de centimes ou chaînes de
télévision pour les quarante minutes de
retard
les responsables argentins ont fait
leurs comptes entre temps et puis on
parle de scandale en allemagne fédérale
à propos de la visite d'un ancien nazi
un pilotes de la luftwaffe hans ulrich
rudel la visite à la résidence de
l'équipe ouest allemande près de cordoba
condamnation générale en allemagne
aujourd'hui de cette visite d'un ancien
nazi auprès de l'équipe ouest allemande
de football
en athlétisme un record du monde le
kenyan henry renault a établi un nouveau
record du monde sur 10000 m aujourd'hui
à vienne
il y a réalisé la performance de 27
minutes 22 secondes et 47 100e donc pour
le dix minutes
en cyclisme vous savez qu'à quelques
jours du départ du tour de france la
grande boucle démarre le 29 juin
vous savez qu'il y ait un cas thévenet
il a abandonné dans le critérium du
dauphiné libéré
et hier dans paris bourges thévenet a
encore abandonné après 175 km de course
alors question sera-t-il suffisamment
prêt pour le départ du tour de france
c'est dire que ce chemin que vraiment je
fais fin prêt le départ du tour de
france c'est autre chose mais enfin
quand même relativement confiance parce
que je pense que d'ici dit cité par du
tout j'aurais fait le des chapes haribo
je suis le midi libre le tour de l'aude
donc je pense arriver à un certain
certain état physique qui me permettent
d'envisager une assez bonne performance
pour touré puis ensuite nan je ne
vaudrait peut-être pas le midi libre le
tour de l'autre où je profite aux fines
et c'est je voulais aborder dauphiné
avec attention de faire vraiment quelque
chose de vraiment faire la course dans
le dauphiné de vraiment courir pour les
premières places alors que j'aurais
peut-être dû me contenter de suivre de
voir venir dix ans le moral vous avez
vraiment moral moral disons que pour
l'instant ça va mais enfin sur les
pointes et maric trop d'ennuis en plus
parce que je pense qu'à la presse c'est
nerveusement ça c'est difficile à
supporter quand même
on attend on attend toujours des
résultats des résultats on est toujours
faire quelque chose de bien
ça devient difficile d'en casser c'est
nerveusement dénoncer ça c'est plus en
cyclisme encore mais pour une petite
promenade de santé cette fois
aujourd'hui dans la forêt de saint
germain en laye il y avait la course de
l'espoir avec deux à trois mille
participants pour prendre son dossard il
fallait donner une petite obole à deux
jeunes médecins chercheurs pour
faciliter leurs travaux pour terminer ce
journal portrait littéraire d' alain
gillot-pétré qui est allé voir chez lui
dans le sud ouest
roger boussinot auteur d'un roman du
terroir marie-jeanne des bernis un roman
qui défend la qualité de la vie face aux
emprises d'une autoroute on devra dans
la gironde 382 habitants qui vivent de
la vigne de l'élevage du maïs et surtout
pas du tourisme tout ici ou presque et
du 12e siècle les maisons les familles
l'église forteresse dont le curé à la
charge de dix autres communes ont doha
et son pont doré le village dont le
maire est un écrivain roger boussinot
qui a créé
marie-jeanne des bernis c'est l'histoire
d'une femme d'une vieille femme qui a 12
ans a été placé chez dans une maison
bourgeoise de 10,6 de la région
peut-être celle ci et qui a vécu pendant
cinquante trois ans au service notamment
d'une personne essentiellement d'une
personne qui avait un nom de plus
qu'elle à peine elle a vécu avec cette
femme jusqu'à l'âge de 65 ans jusqu'au
moment de prendre sa retraite
est ce que marie jeanne n'est pas un peu
le symbole d'un monde qui s'éteint c'est
le symbole d'un monde sait qui c'est en
scène un monde elle-même elle même
incarne amendes qui s'éteint
l'horizon de marie-jeanne c'est le
travail la vie dure sans se plaindre
c'est un personnage du silence oui c'est
un personnage qui ne parlent jamais qui
ne parlent jamais dont on ne parle
jamais mais c'est un personnage qui a
tellement peu l'habitude de se trouver
au premier plan que je pense par exemple
à l'oeuvre de mauriac ou marie jeanne
serait la domestique et toute l'histoire
serait vu sous l'angle de monsieur et
madame là j'ai voulu que ce soir marie
jeanne qui soit au premier plan
leurs fruits de son humilité de son
silence marie jeanne à la fin de sa vie
elle hérite d'une petite maison
madame lui lègue une petite maison avant
de mourir et commence pour elle une
seconde vie une seconde existence et la
seconde existence est un terreau puis
tout d'un coup par un phénomène subi qui
lui tombe dessus comme la foudre
c'est l'autoroute mariam de l'endroit où
elle a vécu là les arbres les aubiers
qui ont été dévastés la source qui a été
capté et tout ça c'est fini
au bénéfice de qui marie-jeanne en
parlait marie-jeanne le savez elles
avaient réfléchi elle connaissait le
monde peut être mieux que nombre de gens
de même la classe politique alizay une
autoroute une voie de communication est
toujours l'instrument d'une conquête la
conquête de qui sûr qu'ils et elles
répondaient n'est plus seulement le
destin de marie jeanne qui est en cause
c'est ce que tout le monde vous défendez
le cadre de vie le cadre de vie et aussi
l'existence peut-être de toute une
classe de la société c'est-à-dire le
paysan celui qui cultive la terre et qui
sans le savoir lui même est en train de
se frustrer de son avenir
mais cette autoroute c'est tout de même
un poumon pour la région pour qui un
poumon pour les villes qui se vident de
leurs habitants
ça n'a rien à voir avec la vie me reste
à vous rappeler le résultat du tiercé
qui suit disputait cette après midi dans
le prix de diane à chantilly le prix
harbi des demoiselles elle a fait des
élégantes aussi sous un très beau soleil
c'est la grande favorite de reine de
saba qui a gagné le 15 devant 6 tuf le
12 et 4 dorina le set résultats donc un
12 et 7 avec pour 5 francs dans l'ordre
un rapport de 457 francs 50 et dans un
ordre différent 91 francs 50 rapport est
pas très élevé sans excès la favorite
qui a gagné le reste à vous donner deux
mots de la météo pour demain également
et bien c'est assez simple le bouton va
persister sur la majeure partie du pays
a noté un qu'il y aura encore des orages
locaux sur les pyrénées le sud du massif
central et les alpes
partout ailleurs après une matinée
fraîche et brumeuse le temps sera
ensoleillé mais près des frontières du
nord-est des nuages passagers pourraient
causer de courte averse avant de se
quitter tout à fait on va revenir
pendant quelques instants sur le match
de football qui se déroule en ce moment
en argentine dominique duvauchelle
j'avais dit rivaux shell apparemment
n'est pas en ligne pour nous et revoici
un tir le tir d'un des avants autrichien
qui passe juste à côté de la cage du
gardien brésilien leao pour l'instant
donc apparemment le score n'a pas changé
le brésil les mercis le brésil mène
toujours par et 0 à quelques secondes de
la fin du match dans le groupe 2 le
match qu'il oppose plutôt un l'autriche
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
donc le résultat de ce match bernard
rapp vous le donnera vers 23h30
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
sur antenne 2